future pro Football Hall of Famer I can
say it I could say it good to see you
Terrell Owens how are you it's been too
long it's been too long I've grown hair
and a mustache see I'm in costume today
to you me too all right who are you how
are you guys today - I'm Terrell today
your teeth look like what would tu look
like in costume a superhero okay maybe
maybe spider-man spider-man
yeah that's your superhero I like that
oh you wouldn't but like what if but if
I were to get hold on a second if I were
to give you cuz you know we like to mix
it up you and I if I to give you one NFL
uniform to be in to play yourself which
one would you choose right now Justin
you know just you view yourself as if
you say I'm going as Terrell Owens I'm
gonna steal for Halloween and you had to
put on an NFL uniform which one would
you choose right now I'll say Kansas
City Chiefs I like Andy Reed
okay but what about from your playing
career
that's a good question man it's a good
question they were probably between the
Eagles and the Cowboys you would not be
the 49ers mmm no okay but between the
eatin you'd go NFC East if you had a
choice yeah because I think I was able
to really really flourish as a receiver
okay especially when I went over to the
Eagles Andy Reid allowed me to really
really kind of spread my wings a little
bit okay no planning well no I know that
and but in terms of Andy Reid though
some might think that your relationship
with him would not be a good one because
he sent you home that one day in
training camp or I know I'm only on a
good level it really I mean I know our
relationship was good I mean he was in a
difficult situation with management and
the hierarchy he it's amazing what he is
doing in Kansas City right now right it
doesn't surprise me at all I mean he's a
great coach I mean when I went there
obviously he saw something to me
obviously playing against me but sure
just my addition to what they already
had and we end up going to the Super
Bowl so everybody's always asked me
who's my favorite
coach that I've ever played with and
it's been him and it's because of his
his football knowledge I know a lot of
people speak of Bill Belichick but you
know Andy Reed is one of the smartest
football minds out there and what he's
doing with that offense right now with
all of those young kids with Hill and
hunt exactly and and and the the thing
that I think he did this year that has
been discussed but I don't think it's
gotten enough credit is when Hunt
fumbled on his first carry of his career
how many coaches would have basically
said okay rookie that's the bench until
you could figure out how to hold on to
the ball you don't get back on the field
and Andy put him right back out there I
was awed I didn't see the game but I
probably would have guessed he probably
no kid I've given the ball right back to
him he did right away yeah I mean that's
just I mean mistakes are gonna happen
that's just part of the game that's the
nature of the game yeah but again is
sensed in what is what is a dream hunt
done I mean he's been phenomenal
phenomenal yeah yeah record game that
game that he put him back in exactly so
I mean it shows you the confidence that
that Andy has in his players and you
think about putting the weapons around
Alex has allowed him to flourish as a
quarterback narrating oh where is this
guy being again when you have a
quarterback and you have weapons around
him again it's gonna make your play
elevate just as well as the guys around
tío is here on the Richardson show which
is the best team that you've seen in the
football that you've been able to sneak
in with all of your practices and
rehearsals for Dancing with the Stars
which one do you think right now looks
the best to you I mean you got to think
about I mean we just talked about in the
Kansas City Chiefs obviously the the
Patriots gonna be be there but and your
other old team the Eagles are seven and
one exactly mean you think about what
Carson and Carson Wentz's doing over
there so right now I mean it's it's kind
of anybody's game I mean you think about
all the teams that were playing well
last year aren't doing so well and you
think about the Atlanta Falcons I mean
they've kind of I don't know if it's a
hangover Superbowl hango or what it
would have have you but you would have
probably would have expected a little
bit more from from from that squad I
mean it's it's it's a lot of parity or
how long along the league right now so
as
the season starts to wind down you're
started to kind of see teams either get
better and try to position themselves
you know for the playoffs or that he's
gonna you know tank it how about this
kid - Shaun Watson - tio oh my god the
text oh my gosh he's he's good he's good
special you can tell right now right I
mean absolutely his numbers are off the
charts right now but Ryan you think
about the way the season started
everybody wondered why he wasn't
starting in the beginning but he in
everything kind of shakes it you know
works itself out and I think as you've
seen the tion he has a lot of I mean he
came from Clemson so he has that
background of really knowing how to play
in big games and he's a guy that doesn't
let the game be too big for him and he's
just playing within himself Terrell
Owens here on the Rich Eisen show and
the the craziest rumor we're hearing of
trade deadline is that who are the teams
the jaguars and who's the other team
Chris Brockman for for the Eagles as
well for Calvin Johnson Calvin Johnson
yes to potentially come out I don't know
if he is or not but somebody's kicking
the tires on that right now what do you
think about that I mean obviously you
know about staying in shape and trying
to think about when that phone rings
what do you think about that I don't I
mean I haven't talked to Calvin much but
I mean you know obviously he were
retired for a reason and obviously is it
with the rumors I mean where there's
smoke there's fire but I think for me I
think that the big trade is is Garoppolo
you know we're going to going to the
Niners but I mean it's one thing to have
a great quarterback in in in him but you
got to have somebody to throw to it at
the same time you know you know so
you're saying if the call is made to
your cell phone I'm always ready talk
about that a lot but I mean seriously
how ready would you be if somebody calls
you right now I'm ready right now I mean
I'll be productive I mean mmm
began to just jump in and and and
continue how else could you give I gave
you 40 on an on a night and average
night the 49ers call you right now
they say Sam Hill I know they got Garcon
they gave anybody okay so let's say that
they call you up how many snaps could
you
somebody right right now against the
against the Cardinals a team that you
know how to play guys least get 30 40
snaps right now yeah
good 30 40 stay right now okay yeah
that's that's what he's rich no no cuz
what no cuz we've had when was the last
time you know we always here I know I
know I know
cuz you because you still you still want
to play I mean you you mean if the
opportunity arises yes it presents
itself then I will make myself available
okay
just like Simeon rice he feels like he
can play Simeon rice could give some
snaps right now I'm pretty sure I mean
nobody nobody can honestly say what a
person can I cannot do until you see
that person do it right age is nothing
but a word when it comes to guys like
myself and and people that have played
well beyond really the years did they
say that they can be productive right I
did it and I honestly believe it that I
can do it I mean there are a lot of
people I'm sure no you can't do how do
you know that we cannot do it or I
cannot do it you've never seen me do it
well you know and the last time we did
have this conversation or the two times
ago we had this conversation well I said
well you going back would push back your
window of getting in the Pro Football
Hall of Fame and then you well then you
said then you said you didn't care about
the Pro Football Hall of Fame and people
took that to mean that you didn't care
about the Pro Football Hall of Fame not
like care about when you get in that
said though the fact that you've had a
couple of cracks to get in and you
haven't gotten in right now I'm curious
is there who's pounding the table for
Terrell Owens in that doesn't have is
there a writer in there that you really
shouldn't have to pound the table if you
put my my stats on a piece of paper
which I have actually that should pound
the table as light as that paper is that
should that should weigh the table down
six-time Pro Bowler 5 first-team all-pro
second most receiving yards in NFL
history only player in NFL history to
score touchdown gets all 32 teams
three-time NFL receiving touchdowns
leader thousand you catch club 15,000
receiving yards club those are just
pounding the table yeah and the test
down
now I get to celebrate on Dancing with
the Stars how's that going every Monday
night you've one of eight Europe you
want to be still in the mix right now
yeah yeah yeah don't want a sex pardon
me what is six remaining participants my
bad you're one of six remaining yeah
who's you oh gosh
you against Frankie Muniz you can take
him out he'll yeah we I mean Frankie's
he's pretty good okay and you know his
partner choreograph whale so okay he's
been showing up every night you enjoying
it yes it's a lot of fun the experience
has been great my partner Cheryl Burke
you know she's she's whipping me into
shape not that I need to be in worse
shape but she's she's but she's been
awesome I mean to be able to progress
you know from week one to where we are
now I mean it's been amazing you know
the staff has been amazing that
everybody all the dancers the pro
dancers the celebrities everybody's been
awesome it really has been a great
experience okay I want to take a break
and come back and stroll down a little
bit of memory lane with you okay I'm
always down for that no I know you're
always down for it
iiiiii I do want to ask the question
about the sharpie okay okay who gave it
to you oh I saw that segment you asked
couch yeah he hadn't he still does not
know okay
Jerry will that be revealed when we come
back coming back okay very good
Terrell Owens when we come back here on
the Rich Eisen show we'll talk a little
bit more dancing with him before Mark
Wahlberg and Brian Windhorse join us in
our number three and if your honor will
take your calls don't go anywhere
you
[Music]
tío here we're gonna chat a little bit
more in the radio audience returns you
know you're here on the set of her day
you know that am i yep right next to my
bust right behind right next to the
Chris tonight King right next to my bust
every day I come and I look at Tio's
nice oh is right that's right tea oh
honey not toasted oats right did you
have a choice and what type of cereal it
was ah no they just tried to be creative
with my initials okay so that was a good
thing when I went to Buffalo mean those
fans are awesome they're amazing and
they tried to have a little playoff the
fruity the flakes booty flakes
okay when Doug Flutie was there so I
thought it was a nice gesture okay we
never opened it it's a limited edition
box you signed it awesome low fat food
right there she's got a got to keep it
got to keep it a healthy stays freshen
did it now seriously
do you ever have a bowl of tea oh
absolutely how could I not they need to
have those on the shelves right now I
think so too
yeah Brockman you think those are good
what's that what's rice the tape look at
the date on over-under that down in my
life she's been out of the league since
2010 so 11 2011 yeah 20 let me sowhat's
these are best if used by August 15th
2010 17 I wonder what those look like in
there I don't want to open a mother
green you think they're still
shrink-wrapped no I'm not going to open
it it's a collector's item yeah Thank
You sorry freshly packed in here I got
those low-fat food I got that sent to me
at at the NFL Network awesome yeah and I
kept it in my office
and I'm like next time I CTO I'm gonna
have him sign that thing and then you
signed it last time absolutely look at
that right now look handsome as ever
tell Teufel what type of cereal would
you want you're dealt to foes like what
would you what would you want if you had
a choice you'd be SpaghettiOs yeah
probably yeah what else don't give my
Diaz
thanks broccoli I just want to see the
wood burning over there underneath that
Wiz which-which
which costume do you like the best out
of all three of us hmm what do you think
you Game of Thrones guy yes the night
King okay I'm not a game you're not
nobody I like you though okay works
Hegel Curb Your Enthusiasm too bad
Terrell Owens of Dancing with the Stars
season 25 airs Mondays at 8:00 Eastern
on ABC good to see you here for one more
segment that's right so we had uh mooch
on um last week he said he had no idea
how the sharpie got in your sock how did
that Sharpie get in your sock that night
in Seattle um we had an equipment guy by
the name of Doc okay and so he was just
happened to be you know walking across
my path and I didn't know what my
touchdown celebration was gonna be at
that moment because this was always the
impromptu so just I don't know it's just
a light bulb just went off and I asked
doc for a for Sharpie and so you the you
know those equipment guys they used it
mark on balls or you know labeling stuff
and so I asked him for the Sharpie he
gave it to me so he just stood there
as I've you know waiting for me to give
it to him give it back to him so I was
like now I think I'm gonna keep it so
he's all right cool
so he didn't know what I was gonna do
with it so when he left I just stuck it
down in my sock and you know the rest is
history the rest is history and you
signed the ball for your it was a mutual
friend
honestly that uh Shawn Springs on
Springs and I had and so I had spoken to
Greg Eastman who was a financial guy and
I think either the day before the game
and he had he said he goes t I need a I
need a I need a sign football from you
you know at some point I'm like alright
ok cool but I didn't really think of it
at that particular time right and so I'm
like oh yeah if like I give you I get
you one and so Joe had just so happen in
real time in the game exactly it just
kind of just worked out that way do you
know where that football is now uh he
has it I think I don't know if I know I
yeah I think I gave it to him you give
it to him in the state understand so I'm
sure he has it somewhere I don't know
where the sharpie is you know the
sharpie I don't know where the Sharpie
is but I not think Greg Guzman has the
football what would your dancing cell
what would your celebration be now let's
say you do get that call oh I don't know
man I'm I mean there's a lots been a lot
of dances you know okay come out since
then I don't know I mean maybe I bring
out one of my my dance routines I may be
the Foxtrot Foxtrot the Viennese Waltz
you know Viennese Waltz something of
this is I don't know if there's as there
ever been a V knees waltz is that
history the national fame you know I'd
be the first guy to do it
uh-huh you know the jive the quickstep
yeah you know would you go out to the
star again uh I don't know it depends it
depends depends it depends I don't think
I mean once it's done it's already done
well you did it on a mini star after you
know big star exactly so I mean I've
already done it I mean it's it's
cemented in history so you always want
to be new and you want to be innovative
and creative right probably wouldn't do
it again okay but you know it's it's
still being talked about years later
absolutely trendsetter
t oh it is good to see you as always
please come back any time
just watch this on Monday night man our
team is team get your popcorn and for
you viewers out there just be sure to
vote vote for me and Cheryl our numbers
at one eight hundred eight six eight
three four one one okay
that's citing pop TV in Japan pop
Corning plugin terrific check it out you
and Cheryl Burke 8:00 Eastern on Monday
one of six left one of six left I love
it tio is here follow him on Twitter at
Terrell Owens since that's your snapchat
as well every Instagram the whole
business everything okay very good when
we come back Mark Wahlberg will be
calling in to the program I'm wonder
what he's got to say about Garoppolo I
think he's got you gotta like it Patriot
fan it's not gonna affect you this
season you know and totally good right
you didn't send him in division Diamond
sentiment conference so we've got him in
the Brian Wynn horse to talk about
everything going on with LeBron when you
come back we'll talk NBA with you to
basketball I know yes I know yes as the
seasons gonna get getting almost a month
old already that's coming up and then
your phone calls at April for 2:04 rich
that's next year on the Rich Eisen show
for more Rich Eisen show tuned -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
the Rich Eisen show app